[Musique]
Claude tu as créé il y a 13 ans un 13
avril une société de production de
cinéma que tu as appelé les films 13 tu
viens de sortir ton 13e film diffusé en
circuit commercial et la première a eu
lieu le vendredi 13 avril
ce film est actuellement diffusé dans 13
cinéma de la région parisienne est-ce
que cela signifie que tu es ou que tu
n'es pas sup
erstits
superstitieux mais je tiens tout de
suite à préciser que pour moi la
superstition c'est une science c'est une
science il y a des gens qui sont
superstitieux comme d'autres parle
anglais ou l'italien ou l'espagnol et je
suis devenu superstitieux le jour où
j'ai regardé dans un microscope
je vois comme ça un camarade m'a fait
regarder dans un microscope et j'ai vu
dans ce microscope des choses que mes
yeux ne voyaient pas et puis je suis je
me suis aperçu que mes oreilles
n’entendaient pas tout et que l'ensemble
de mes sens est illimité
alors à partir de ce moment là je suis
devenu superstitieux parce que je me
suis dit vraiment ne pas être
superstitieux c'est une telle forme de
prétention c'est tellement croire que
l'on est un être suprême
puis à superstition permet de ramener
l'homme à sa juste valeur je veux dire
que on s'aperçoit qu'on n'est pas grand
chose et qu'on peut être en même temps
énormément de choses
alors étant conscient que nous étions
limités dans nos sens j'ai essayé de
comprendre pourquoi il y avait des
choses que nous ne pouvions pas voir des
choses que nous ne pouvions pas entendre
il y a partir de ce moment-là j'ai
appris le langage des superstitieux qui
est un langage qui n'en finit pas de
s'apprendre d'ailleurs qui est à mon
sciences scientifique et qui vous donne
des points de repère sur des choses que
l'on ne peut pas deviner à l'avance mais
que seule la superstition et les
superstitieux peuvent sentir on ne peut
pas le savoir d'une façon précise mais
on peut le sentir on peut le sentir de
la même façon qu'il y a des gens qui
vous disent tient de mal tant sera
couvert demain il fera beau et de la
même façon que la météo peut prévoir le
temps les superstitieux peuvent prévoir
à plus ou moins long échéances un
certain nombre de choses comme ça parce
que parce que
il se passe dans la vie et plus ou moins
prévu à plus ou moins longue échéance
cela veut dire que tu crois aux astres
et au signe des astres je crois aux
astres je crois aussi je crois tout ce
dont on ne peut pas me prouver le
contraire je suis croyant par définition
je crois à tout voilà et quand je cesse
de croire à quelque chose c'est parce
qu'un ami m'a trahi alors je ne crois
plus en lui parce qu'une femme m'a
trompé alors je ne crois plus en elle
mais je dis que tant qu'on ne m'a pas
trompé autant qu'on ne m'a pas prouvé
qu'une chose n'existait pas je croise en
elle alors comme personne n'a pu me
prouver que Dieu n'existait pas je crois
en Dieu je crois dans tous les dieux
viens je crois en tout je suis un
croyant je suis le type même de croyant
jusqu'à ce que l'on me prouve que mes
croyances ne sont fondées sur rien car
ce que j'ai vu dans ce microscope était
absolument
fabuleux j'étais vraiment à des
kilomètres de de pouvoir m'imaginer ce
que je voyais
en plus maintenant je fais des études
là-dessus enfin j'essaye de comprendre
le pourquoi et le comment de certaines
choses et je sais que la superstition
est
aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose
d'anecdotique c'est quelque chose de
dérisoire enfin je veux dire ça fait
rire quand on dit je suis superstitieux
mais pour moi c'est une chose qui
devient de plus en plus sérieuse et qui
en fait est mon violon je veux dire
après le cinéma c'est une de mes
passions cela dit je lui accorde
l'importance qu'il faut lui accorder et
puis les superstitieux sont joueurs je
veux dire dès que je vois un joueur
quelque part je sais qui c'est un gars
de mon clan je veux dire je sais que
c'est un c'est un superstitieux et comme
je suis de plus en plus joueur je sais
donc je suis vraiment un vrai
superstitieux
on va redescendre des des astres des
signes du zodiaque de la superstition au
cinéma qui est ton métier même si la
superstition est en violent d’ingres
je voudrais te poser une question
comment dirait en langage actuel
fondamental
est-ce que tu vas beaucoup peau cinéma
voir les films des autres et est-ce que
ces deux questions en une et est-ce que
tu te considères comme un cinéphile
je vais énormément au cinéma
et je vais voir aussi facilement les
mauvais films que les bons films car
j'ai appris mon métier en voyant les
mauvais films un bon film on apprend
rien c'est parfait c'est bon ça roule
tout seul on voit passer les deux heures
on sort de là on a rien appris je dis on
a été bouleversé on a été ému on ne peut
pas apprendre ce qu'il faut faire on
apprend ce qu'il ne faut pas faire
absolument enfin moi je sais que ma
passion du cinéma est venue en voyant de
très très mauvais films à 7 huit ans
quand j'ai commencé à aller au cinéma et
peut-être même avant j'habitais un
quartier boulevard de Strasbourg on ne
passe que de très mauvais films même
aujourd'hui film porno western de
dernière catégorie
j'allais voir ces films et c'est sans
ces films qui m'ont donné l'enthousiasme
du cinéma j'étais fasciné ça bougeait
c'était n'importe quoi mais c'était
fabuleux bon alors après j'ai découvert
qu'il y avait un autre cinéma après j'ai
découvert qu'il y avait des films de
qualité j'ai même découvert la
Cinémathèque française par la suite où
je me suis profondément ennuyé
et
mais ma passion du cinéma est venue de
très mauvais films je pourrai pas vous
dire c'est un tel un tel un tel qui
m'ont donné la passion du cinéma non les
les metteurs en scène qui m'ont donné la
passion du cinéma sont de tristes
inconnus qui n'ont aucun talent qui
aujourd'hui n'existe plus
j'ai eu la passion du cinéma pour le
cinéma et j'ai appris mon métier de
cinéaste en allant voir des films
populaires
et en allant de très mauvais films c'est
là que j'ai pris mes grandes leçons de
cinéma parce que quand je vais voir un
mauvais film je j'ai envie de faire la
révolution tout est toutes les 10
secondes j'ai envie de tout casser j'ai
envie de je vois tout ce qui est mauvais
bon alors je le ressens tellement
profondément que je ne le ferai plus
jamais que pour moi c'est la vraie leçon
mais quand une chose est parfaite quand
elle est belle quand elle quand elle
quand elle est réussie il y a pas de
leçon à tirer il y a que du plaisir à
prendre je t'ai posé une question en te
demandant si tu étais cinéphile tu te
considérais comme un cinéphile tu as
répondu un peu d'ailleurs par un bien en
disant qu'elle a Cinémathèque tu
t'ennuies beaucoup
oui je m'ennuie parce que
j'ai mis parce que les films de
Cinémathèque aujourd'hui ne sont pas des
films basés sur le plaisir
pour moi je crois que l'art commence
avec le plaisir
et tout tard qui ne donne pas du plaisir
à mon sens n'est pas artistique
je veux pas dire qu'elle a Cinémathèque
on s'ennuie systématiquement
mais on peut dire que 80% des films qui
sont passés à la Cinémathèque ne sont
pas sous fondés sur le plaisir
et je dois dire que mes grands moments
de bonheur je veux être sincère je veux
pas être je vais être sincère mais
grands moments de bonheur je les ai pris
dans des salles populaires et non pas la
Cinémathèque je veux dire mon vrai
plaisir du cinéma je l'ai pris sur les
grands boulevards je l'ai pris aux
Champs-Élysées beaucoup plus que dans
les cinémas d'art et essai ou qu'elle a
cinéma tech elle a cinéma tech j'ai
appris ce qu'était le cinéma le vrai
cinéma j'ai appris ce qu'était la
technique la vraie technique je dis il y
a eu un moment où j'étais prêt à la
Cinémathèque mais si j'étais resté toute
ma vie un simple spectateur un
spectateur qui aime le cinéma pour aller
au cinéma et qui veut pas se cultiver en
allant au cinéma je n'aurais jamais été
à la Cinémathèque le plaisir le bonheur
c'est à dire
des grands moments qui font que on sort
enthousiaste que l'on a envie de chanter
qu'on a envie de danser qu'on a envie de
parler qu'on a envie de tomber amoureux
je les ai pris dans des salles
populaires quelle est l'importance de la
pour un cinéaste j'entends de la culture
cinématographique
pour un cinéaste elle est elle est
importante et en même temps elle est
encombrante
moi j'ai une théorie sur la culture qui
va sûrement faire frémir beaucoup de
gens mais je pense que la culture
ne doit être mise entre les mains que de
gens très très très intelligents c'est
comme une voiture de course il faut la
mettre entre les mains que d'un grand
conducteur
c'est une des choses les plus
fantastiques qui soient que la culture
mais si on met la culture entre les
mains des imbéciles ça leur rend
vraiment les pires inconvénients parce
que qu'est-ce qu'il y a terrible dans la
culture la culture c'est un petit peu
comme si tu me racontais l'histoire d'un
film que je vais aller voir dans deux
heures
et bien si je fais frère ce film dans
deux heures et que tu m'as raconté toute
l'histoire j'ai plus envie de le voir le
film bon alors la culture a un avantage
c'est qu'elle prévient c'est comme les
panneaux sur la route pour vous dire il
y a un croisement il y a s'il y en a
mais elle vous supprime tout effet de
surprise et je crois que le grand
bonheur dans la vie si on veut analyser
le bonheur le bonheur c'est la surprise
c'est l'étonnement alors je crois qu'il
vaut mieux réinventer la vie tous les
jours en étant moins cultivé en se
cultivant soi-même qu'en ayant une
culture d'emblée
imprime toutes les joies de la
découverte je crois que le grand
problème aujourd'hui de la culture c'est
qu'elle enlève toute la jeunesse les
joies de l'étonnement et de la
découverte
et je sais que pour moi le grand bonheur
c'est la découverte pourquoi je me lance
constamment dans des aventures que je ne
connais pas ou dans des directions
différentes c'est pour découvrir des
choses pourquoi je vais toujours d'un
individu à un autre d'une femme à une
autre c'est parce que ce goût de la
découverte bon j'aime une femme si cette
femme que j'aime tu me l'expliques en
détail tu m'expliques toute sa culture
au moment où je vais frapper à sa porte
je n'ai plus envie d'aller voir cette
femme si j'ai la culture de cette femme
afin d'aller lui faire l'amour ce n'est
plus possible pour moi mais j'aime bien
arriver chez elle en sachant absolument
pas qui allait j'ai besoin du mystère
j'ai besoin de la réinventer de la
redécouvrir pour moi la culture c'est la
redécouverte de la vie par soi-même
alors cela dit ce que je dis est un
petit peu excessif c'est pour ça que je
dis que la culture l'agriculture doit
être mise entre les mains de gens très
très intelligents qui savent l'utiliser
c'est comme toutes les drogues c'est
comme tous les excitants c'est comme
toutes ces choses dangereuses elles ne
peuvent être mises entre les mains que
les gens qui savent que c'est dangereux
et qui ne peuvent s'en servir comment
apprécie on en a besoin essentiels par
conséquent ce que ce que tu penses de la
culture cinématographe pour un cinéaste
pour le cinéaste que tu es et valable de
la culture dans son ensemble absolument
moi ça régit tes rapports en général
avec la culture bien entendu je n'ai
suivi aucune école cinématographique
pourquoi j'ai pris un plaisir fou à
faire tous mes films c'est parce qu'à
chaque fois que je faisais un film
j'avais la sensation d'inventer le
cinéma je n'avais pas été à l'école je
ne savais pas ce que c'était qu'un
objectif je sais pas ce que c'était
qu'une caméra je sais pas ce que c'était
que la pellicule je sais pas ce que
c'est qu'un acteur j'ai découvert ce qui
était un metteur en scène à l'âge de 13
ans alors j'allais au cinéma depuis 6
ans je croyais que c'était les acteurs
qui inventé le texte je veux dire que ma
culture si on avait donné une culture on
m'aurait dit ça beaucoup plus on
m'aurait dit ça avant alors j'ai tout
découvert par moi-même et je veux dire
que la culture que j'ai reçu et qui
aujourd'hui grandit avec les années elle
me gêne plutôt qu'autre chose parce que
souvent maintenant il y a des choses que
je sais et je n'ose pas faire certaines
choses parce que je sais que je laissais
alors que si je ne le savais pas je les
ferai la culture donne de la peur aux
gens j'ai des gens cultivés sont
trouillards je veux dire un homme
courageux n'a moins de culture je veux
dire la culture vous fait peur moi des
choses que je sais que les gens cultivés
sont trouillard parce qu'ils ont peur de
ne pas être assez cultivés entre autres
mais ils ont ils ont ils ont peur ils
ont peur du résultat puisque dans leur
culture ils ont lu la conclusion et ils
ont vu que ça se terminait
dramatiquement par exemple dans une
pièce classique on sait que tout le
monde meurt à la fin alors on le fait
pas puisqu'on sait qu'on va mourir mais
si on a une chance de survivre ou si on
ne sait pas moi je déteste les gens qui
vont voir des voyants je déteste les
gens qui nous donnent la météo tous les
jours je veux dire ces gens-là me
gâchent mon plaisir tu es superstitieux
et tu n'aimes pas les voyantes et tu
n'aimes pas connaître ton avenir j'aime
le déceler j'aime sentir des signes qui
me disent tiens je suis sur la bonne
route
mon problème c'est d'aller sur une route
mais je crois que c'était un indien
c'est moi aussi qui me racontait ça un
jour il me disait
qu'un indien lui avait dit un jour
il y a des milliers de chemin
et tous ces chemins mènent nulle part
alors comment choisir un parmi tout cela
et bien il faut prendre un chemin qui a
un cœur voilà et bien
toute ma vie est basée là-dessus je sais
que tous les chemins que je prends
mènent mèneront nulle part maintenant je
sais depuis qu'on m'a dit ça mais à
chaque fois que j'ai besoin d'en choisir
un j'essaie de trouver un cœur donc un
type sympa ou une fille sympa
et que ça donc il y a pas de problème je
peux faire toute la route que je veux
alors quand je dis que la culture est
dangereuse aujourd'hui je crois que tout
ce qui se passe avec la jeunesse
aujourd'hui c'est parce que justement on
leur donne une culture
qu'il est qu'il est bloque qui leur fait
peur parce que cette culture leur a
annoncé tellement de choses qu'elle
limite leurs rêves c'est à dire que
c'est une culture qui leur donne
peut-être envie d'en savoir davantage
mais pas exactement d'apprendre par
eux-mêmes exact ça les rend
ça leur coupe ce goût de l'aventure
celui de la découverte je vais te poser
une question qui pourra paraître
indiscrète et n'est pas indiscrète entre
nous parce que j'en connais à peu près
la réponse mais je pense que la réponse
que tu vas faire va servir à mieux
t'expliquer vis-à-vis des
téléspectateurs qui ne te connaissent
que par tes films dans tes études
tu es allé jusqu'où
pas très loin pas très loin je suis allé
jusque jusqu'à l'écrit du premier bac
parce que je me suis fait recaler
volontairement à l'oral parce que mon
père avait dit à ma mère la veille de
l'oral la maladie qu'est-ce qu'on fera
mon père j'achèterai une caméra il fera
du cinéma puisqu'il a la passion de ça
donc le lendemain je me suis fait
recaler à l'oral et donc je suis allé
que jusque là mais c'est un miracle même
si je suis allé jusque là parce que
j'étais pas fait pour recevoir la
culture je veux dire qu'à chaque fois
j'entendais un professeur parler à
chaque fois que j'ai entendu quelqu'un
me dire des choses j'ai refusé ces
choses-là je les ai refusé parce que ça
ne m'intéressait pas qu'on me dise la
fin du film je supporte pas les gens qui
racontent la fin de mon film parce qu'il
y a quelque chose d'extraordinaire qui
me qui m'étonne toujours quand je vois
des films et je crois que je les ai à
peu près 12 vues
c'est que ces films tu les réalisent tu
les films toi-même tu es à la fois ton
propre metteur en scène ton opérateur
tu les écris donc tu écris un scénario
tu écris des dialogues et tu n'es pas un
écrivain du tout tu ne te considères pas
comme un écrivain non mais aussi
ce sont des dialogues je parle toute la
journée je suis en train de parler donc
je suis capable de faire des dialogues
alors j'écris jamais avec une plume
parce que c'est pas
physiquement pour moi ce n'est pas un
plaisir que d'écrire avec une plume ou
avec un stylo mais j'écris avec un
magnétophone alors j'ai j'ai un
magnétophone et je parle pendant des
heures pendant des heures et des heures
et des heures et des heures après je
donne ça à mes secrétaires qui retape
tout ça et après je relis tout ça je
découvre moi-même un roman et je choisis
dans tout ça ce qui peut faire
intéressant de tes de tes études et du
point jusqu'où tu avais mené des études
tout à l'heure parce que bon il apparaît
quand on te voit quand on te connaît
même pour quelqu'un qui te découvre on
imagine que tu n'es pas licencié en
psychologie et encore moins heureusement
en sociologie et pourtant quand on
regarde tes films on s'aperçoit que
dans la
découverte de tes personnages
tu vas aussi loin que tu veux tu vas
aussi loin que tu veux dans l'âme de tes
personnages avec disons pour parler en
termes de référence littéraire avec la
force de pénétration et l'acuité d'un
Mauriac peut-être et avec la simplicité
d'un Fromentin ou d'un Flaubert dans tes
dialogues et dans la façon dont tu mènes
non seulement dans tes dialogues mais
dans la façon dont tu écris tes
scénarios dont tu construis des
scénarios et ça c'est très curieux c'est
très impressionnant est-ce que tu en es
conscient que ça repousse sur une
sensibilité je veux dire moi ma grande
passion c'est c'est la découverte des
hommes je veux dire que toute ma vie est
basée là-dessus
géographiquement je m'ennuie partout où
je vais quel que soit le pays où je vais
je m'ennuie
quand je voyage c'est pour rencontrer
des hommes si c'est pour aller me
montrer un like une chaîne de montagne
ça m'ennuie prodigieusement pour moi ça
n'a strictement aucun intérêt la seule
chose qui me passionne véritablement ce
sont les individus donc depuis 35 ans je
n'ai pas cessé d'approcher les individus
d'essayer de comprendre non pas ce qu'il
disait mais ce qu'ils pensent alors
c'est normal qu'à la longue je l'ai
comprenne et puis en plus non seulement
j'ai essayé de le comprendre mais j'ai
essayé de vivre des tas de vie je veux
dire ma vie personnelle privée et
complètement folle mais elle est folle
peut-être justement afin de mieux
approcher tous ces problèmes car en fait
je ne parle dans mes films que de choses
que j'ai appris la veille en fait je
suis comme ces gens qui cite une phrase
de Voltaire à table parce qu'il en lui
la veille bon et bien dans mes films
c'est pareil tout ce que je raconte dans
la bonne année c'est ce que j'ai appris
l'année dernière
qu'il y avait dans un homme une femme
c'était la veille je veux dire en fait
chacun de mes films est un devoir pour
savoir si ce que j'ai appris fonctionne
et si c'est valable donc c'est comme ça
qu'il faut le prendre on a l'impression
que dans chacun de tes films tu es sur
le plan de la maturité donc de la
connaissance
de des personnages autrement dit de la
connaissance de l'homme et de la femme
que tu es en avance sur ton âge et sur
ton expérience parce que
je sais que je vis à 300 à l'heure je
vis à 300 à l'heure je sais que par
exemple je dors très peu alors le fait
de dormir très peu m'oblige déjà
pratiquement à vivre deux fois plus vite
je dors en moyenne trois heures trois
heures et demie par nuit bon donc je vis
deux fois plus qu'une personne qui dort
8 heures ou 10 heures alors c'est normal
qu'il se passe des choses en plus je
provoque constamment ma vie pour qu'il
se passe des choses par exemple je
supporte pas les vacances je m'ennuie en
vacances alors je m'invente des trucs je
m'invente je crée des sociétés je me
lance dans des affaires de bateau de
l'immobilier mais tout ça nous fera pour
l'argent mais tout simplement pour qu'il
se passe constamment quelque chose et
pour aller à la chasse en fait je suis
un chasseur non pas d'image mais d'idées
après les images viennent d'elles-mêmes
mais je vais tous les jours chasser ma
nourriture pour le métier que j'aime
par-dessus tout qui est le cinéma et la
mise en scène mais je ne peux pas parler
d'une chose dans un film si je ne l'ai
pas vécu
lire un livre pour moi c'est
c'est bien c'est bien mais ça ne vous le
verse pas mais voir une femme qui pleure
ou qui me dit je t'aime ou qui me sert
très fort dans ses bras ça m'en dit 10
fois plus que 25 bouquins sur n'importe
quoi à ce moment-là je suis bouleversé
parce que ça me touche au fond de
moi-même alors à ce moment-là je peux le
ressortir mais j'ai besoin de vivre une
chose sinon je ne la prends pas si
demain matin je prends des quand j'étais
petit mon père était complètement
désolé de voir à quel point j'étais
ignore en classe il me donnait des sons
particulières ça ne change strictement
rien un type qui veut m'apprendre
quelque chose ça ne m'intéresse pas mais
si ce passe quelque chose si je suis
obligé de vivre une chose alors je la
prends et je l'assimile très vite tu
viens de parler de ton père
et tu as dit que lorsqu'il essayait de
te donner des leçons particulières ça ne
te servait pas à grand chose et pourtant
tu vas dire à jour que la seule personne
qui avait été importante dans ta vie qui
avait été déterminante au seul maître ça
a été ton père absolument quand je dis
qu'il Daniel elles sont particulières
c'était avec des professeurs
non il m'a tout appris c'est vrai il m'a
tout appris il m'a tout appris
d'ailleurs parce que lui-même n'avait
aucune culture et que qu'est-ce qu'il
faisait Ton père il était commerçant il
était commerçant du côté de boulevard de
Strasbourg il avait un petit un petit
une petite fabrique de coussin
d'ameublement
et il avait une connaissance des hommes
absolument exceptionnels j'ai jamais
rencontré un homme qui connaissait les
hommes comme mon père il avait une
philosophie comme ça étonnante généreuse
il savait exactement où il était ce
qu'il fallait faire et je me rappelle
que dès l'âge de 7 ans il m'a dit les
choses les plus importantes qu'on ait pu
me dire
même que n'importe qui est plus dire je
veux dire ça m'a frappé d'une façon
absolument incroyable il m'a appris les
gens la vie il m'a donné quelques
conseils absolument fantastiques
il m'a très vite expliqué que je vivais
dans une société capitaliste il m'a très
très bien expliqué ce que c'était il m'a
dit c'est pas pire qu'une autre société
enfin c'est une société capitaliste
alors tu vas vivre dans une société Kaby
il faut que je t'apprenne le capitalisme
si ma matin tu voulais jouer à la belote
je t'apprendrai la belote et il m'a
appris les règles du capitalisme en fait
elles sont très simples
et puis il m'a dit bon si demain matin
on vivait dans une société il m'a dit ça
serait beaucoup mieux pour toi si tu
vives dans une société socialiste ça
serait beaucoup plus calme qu'est-ce que
tu vas t'ennuyer il m'a dit tout de
suite il m'a dit il vaut mieux aller à
la guerre tous les matins
plutôt que de s'ennuyer dans sa chambre
bon c'était des théories qui avaient mon
père par exemple il m'a dit que tu
verras tu auras sûrement des moments
très très difficiles et peut-être un
jour tu n'auras pas d'argent dis-toi que
l'argent est la chose la plus simple du
monde à gagner ce qu'il faut c'est faire
croire aux autres que tu en as à partir
de ce moment-là tous les problèmes
seront simplifiés
quand on vous dit ça dans un square ou
dans un appartement ça vous sort de la
tête et puis arrive une époque où
effectivement vous n'avez plus d'argent
vous n'avez plus rien et si cette phrase
vous revient en mémoire et que vous la
mettez en application vous apercevez
qu'il a raison par exemple j'ai une
anecdote qui frappante
c'était je me rappelle en 62 et une
époque où ça allait très très mal même
la société était pratiquement en
faillite j'étais sur le point de de tout
abandonner ma société vitre
et je travaillais pour un copain Gérard
cire qui me faisait faire des Scopitone
qui me faisait travailler et puis un
jour Gérard qui joue un rôle dans un
film qui joue dans la bonne année le
rôle du directeur de la prison et qui
est d'ailleurs un personnage fétiche
dans ma vie parce que c'est un être que
j'aime beaucoup et un jour j'ai alors si
je vais le voir je frappe j'ai dit
écoutez Gérard tu me dois 5 millions là
ça fait quand même un an que je
travaille bien que tu me payes Gérard
traverser à l'époque aussi une très très
mauvaise passe il me dit écoute attends
un petit peu parce qu'en ce moment je
suis très gêné je dis écoute je suis
vraiment gonflé tu viens de t'acheter
une Mercedes de 6 brick et j'arrive pas
à me payer Gérard un peu scandalisé
c'est vrai c'était un petit peu gros
parce qu'en plus le matin il avait un
peu frimé avec cette voiture devant tout
le monde dit ben écoute fais une chose
prends la voiture va la vendre et puis
tu payes avec
tu prends la voiture je roule 500 mètres
dedans et comme c'était la plus belle
voiture du monde à l'époque j'ai la
drogue je dis je peux pas vendre ça
c'est pas vrai
et puis pendant que je cherchais à la
vendre je prends un copain à moi qui
était sur les sur les Champs-Élysées
avec qui j'avais rendez-vous qui monte
dans ma voiture et je lui fais croire
pendant 5 minutes que c'est ma voiture
et il m'a prêté 20 millions il a prêté
20 millions parce qu'il était dans une
belle voiture parce que je l'ai rassuré
je lui ai fait croire que j'avais de
l'argent j'ai plus jamais vendu cette
voiture j'ai même mis un faux téléphone
dedans et je donnais tous mes
rendez-vous d'affaires dedans puisque
mon bureau où était minable ma chambre
de bonne était sordide j'avais une
voiture formidable je faisais toutes mes
affaires dans cette voiture et j'ai
monté vraiment la société les films 13
dans cette voiture parce qu'elle
rassurait les gens et mon père m'avait
dit fais croire aux gens que tu as de
l'argent et tu verras tu en auras bon et
comme les gens ont peur parce que c'est
vrai que la base même de l'époque dans
laquelle nous vivons c'est la peur mon
père me l'a bien dit il m'a dit qu'il va
avoir la grande force que tu risques
d'avoir c'est que tout le monde a peur
les gens sont terrorisés ils vivent la
panique en permanence bon
alors il faut avoir un tout petit peu
moins peur que je te dis pas de pas
avoir peur mais un tout petit peu moins
peur était sauvé
et c'est vrai que quand vous les
rassurez avec une voiture vous les
rassurez avec un appartement vous les
rassurez il vous faut une confiance
totale les gens détestent qu'on a eu
leur demander de l'argent ce qu'ils
veulent c'est que vous le rend Deniez
bon alors il faut leur faire croire
qu'on va leur en donner même si on doit
leur en donner par la suite donc c'est
une démarche de départ ce qu'il faut
c'est rassurer les gens à Monsieur ne
vous prête pas d'argent s'il se dit on
me le remboursera pas oui ce qui
s'exprime
alors ça c'est une anecdote ça c'est
pour l'argent et pour le talent
il a pas pu m'expliquer parce que
parce que moi-même je peux pas expliquer
une chose comme ça je veux dire que
le talent d'abord qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire
moi je sais pas si j'ai du talent je
sais que j'invente et que j'ai de
l'invention je veux que je suis jamais à
cours d'idée voilà
alors maintenant est-ce que c'est une
forme de talent ou pas mais je sais que
tu as l'impression après ton ton 13e
film qui est d'ailleurs ton 15e enfin il
y en a deux qui sont pas sorti est-ce
que tu as l'impression qu'au point de
vue ne parlons pas de talent puisque
c'est difficile pour un créateur de
parler de son talent ou du talent en
général mais ce que tu as l'impression
que tu es un stade de ton métier de ta
connaissance de ton métier qui te donne
une maturité suffisante pour
pour faire ce que tu veux tu as toujours
fait à peu près ce que tu voulais mais
enfin maintenant est-ce que tu as
l'impression que tu as franchi un degré
dans le dans la possibilité de faire ce
que l'on veut en fait ces
contradictoires est-ce que je disais
tout à l'heure mais il faut un minimum
de culture quand même
jusqu'à maintenant je travaillais à
l'instant
mais pendant ces 13 ans où j'ai fait des
longs métrages j'ai appris un nombre
incroyable de choses sur le cinéma ce
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui je suis je crois
au moment précis où je peux faire mes
meilleurs films je crois que c'est
l'époque actuelle parce que j'ai
suffisamment de métiers donc de culture
et encore d'un Stains
alors que dans 5 ou 10 ans je n'aurais
peut-être un peu trop de culture et un
peu moins d'instin et je risque d'être
sur le déclin donc je pense que très
sincèrement en ce moment la synthèse de
cette culture dont on a parlé tout à
l'heure de cet instinct auquel je tiens
et sur laquelle j'ai basé entièrement ma
vie et peut-être actuellement
au point le plus le plus favorable pour
faire les deux ou trois films que
j'espère faire dans les années à venir
qui seront à mon sens de bons films
avant avant un homme une femme qui ont
été commercialement des échecs quels
souvenir tu en as maintenant et comment
les regarde tu
c'est le plus beau placement que j'ai pu
faire je veux dire c'est avec ces films
c'est avec ces films que j'ai appris ce
qu'il fallait pas faire je veux dire
c'est films m'ont appris à faire des
films c'est ce que je disais
dans les erreurs qu'on apprend tout je
veux dire c'est c'est il faut il faut il
faut des catastrophes dans la vie des
hommes je veux dire il faut des
cicatrices bon plus on a cicatrices plus
on a de chance de s'en sortir le
problème c'est cicatriser très vite vous
avez des gens qui cicatrisent très vite
d'autres qui sait qui attristent pas
alors moi je sais que je suis assez très
vite un échec je l'enquête je le prends
comme ça mais au bout de jus j'y pense
plus mais je l'assimule je l'assimule
d'une façon formidable par exemple le
propre de l'homme qui a été le bide au
sommet qui était mon toutou premier film
qui m'a même mis en difficulté
financière m'a appris des choses mais
que aucun livre aucun professeur que
personne n'aurait pu m'apprendre parce
que j'ai touché vraiment le fond
quand on touche le fond on s'aperçoit
que qu'il y a des choses au fond qu'on
ne soupçonne pas quand certains
critiquent disent de tes films que ce
sont des films
réactionnaires que tu fais un cinéma
bourgeois comment réagis tu
chacun est libre de dire ce qu'il a
envie de dire je veux dire que
on saura si les critiques ont raison ou
tort dans plusieurs années et on sera si
j'ai raison ou tard aussi dans plusieurs
années pour l'instant j'ai la sensation
de faire des films à la mode voilà et
pour moi c'est pas péjoratif la chose
qui m'importe le plus c'est le présent
j'aime trop le plaisir j'aime trop le
cash j'aime trop les choses que je peux
toucher que je peux voir donc je fais
des films qui concernent mon époque donc
je fais des films qui sont à la mode
mais je le dis bien c'est pas péjoratif
pour moi et tu ne laissais pas tu penses
qu'ils ont à la mode mais tu ne les fais
pas pour qu'il soit à la mode pas du
tout je l'ai fait ils sont à la mode
parce que je vis synchrone avec mon
époque parce que je m'intéresse à tout
ce qui se passe parce que je lis tout ce
qui se passe tous les jours parce que je
vois à la télé tout ce qui se passe
parce que je vois tous les films qui
sortent parce que je suis synchrone avec
mon époque et que ce qui me passionne
c'est mon époque moi ce qui se passera
dans 10 ans je m'en fous complètement et
ce qui se passe il y a 10 ans je m'en
fous complètement ce qui m'intéresse
c'est 73 en plein donc je vis 73 en
place qui fait que quand mes films
sortent il marche c'est parce que c'est
73 parce que les gens puisent dans mes
films peut-être je dis peut-être et
c'est peut-être pour ça l'explication de
de leur succès des choses qui leur sont
nécessaires tout de suite mais tout de
suite alors c'est bien connu quand un
monsieur achète une maison et qui dit
monsieur je vous paye cash et l'autre il
joue pas avec des traits sur 20 ans ces
deux optiques totalement différents bon
moi je les traits ça va pas monsieur qui
me joue pas sur 20 ans ça ne m'intéresse
pas il faut me payer tout de suite bon
ben mon cinéma c'est comme ça moi je
paye tout de suite quand je fais un film
c'est pour des gens c'est un c'est un
objet de consommation immédiat bon donc
tu as le sentiment que ton cinéma n'est
ni d'avant en gare de ni conservateur ni
progressiste ni réactionnel c'est un
cinéma d'aujourd'hui
et l'avenir nous dira si c'est à nous
aujourd'hui qui vieillit bien qui
vieillit mal mais c'est pas les
critiques qui peuvent le dire ni moi la
seule chose que je puisse dire
aujourd'hui c'est que c'est un cinéma
d'aujourd'hui
qui se sert de technique de pointe parce
que je suis passionné par les techniques
de pointe je viens de tourner la bonne
année avec une caméra que personne
n'avait jamais utilisé qui est une
caméra portable sonore ça dit rien du
tout au téléspectateur mais pour moi ça
veut tout dire ça veut dire que d'un
seul coup j'ai fait un film subjectif un
film qui colle complètement aux
personnages parce que d'un seul coup
j'ai libéré la caméra de son éternel
pied de sa technique de sa lumière de
ses projecteurs de ces artifices de ces
maquillages
je sais que je fais un cinéma
d'aujourd'hui
et je n'ai pas envie de faire un cinéma
d'avant-garde
parce que ça c'est prétentieux et je
n'ai pas en fait envie de faire un
cinéma sur le passé parce que le passé
je m'en souviens pas j'ai pas de mémoire
alors je fais vraiment un cinéma
d'aujourd'hui alors quand on dit que je
suis un cinéaste réactionnaire quand je
fais l'aventure c'est l'aventure
peut-être
et plus de réactionnaire qu'autre chose
peut-être que je m'identifie
aux gens avec lesquels je vis
peut-être mais ça c'est il faut attendre
un petit peu maintenant pour savoir qui
a raison qui a tort merci Claude au
revoir bon après-midi
[Musique]